експерти аналітичну платформу vox
юкрейн ви спочатку цим економічних
проблем вирішити через річки українська
економіка у катастрофічно must вони
гаманців та та нацбанк ціна думка фторида
сліди жодна знає найголовніших проблем
над банками mazda стадник ваші риф пливу
та фактично стала vr стартом для
іншого не кришим ще приходять і дефіцит
бюджету купити сумку та щедро душ і знати
і не волосся на момент революції
жирності та ряд move раптом вата для
нафтогазу близько 100 мільярдів гривень та
через cc стала однією з ключових во жили
в інфляції та девальвації гривні та
в 14 15 руках там ще душу багату в
гаю ці було не підкріплення
економічним станом води були просто
на іншого не ручне регулювання
center експорту та ряди боролася з
інфляцію адміністративними методами
все справило так по de mi var
вбивство розвитку бартерних схем
ваучерна приватизація видалено стебло 6
населення не смагляве keys але ви кури
Стати свої ваучер і так дзвони червоне
директор і від рима до цього жили в
пливу
до приватизації допустив і вище
бізнесмен ним близькі до влади ділися
олігархи
викрали нас система стилю і преференцій
і броні компанії малий пили віриш то за
них платив їм спеціальні економічні
зони за словом автореф das lied дружина
став і механізму муфелю не безкоштовний
подарунки і краще заводили притоку
іноземних інвестицій мораторії на продаж
сільгосп землі через оборону на продаж
сільгосп по землі за різьбленими оцінками
держава над три малавит 40 до 50
мільярдів доларів і найголовніше ти
заражаю розвідку в агру сектором і
створи не
цивілізованого ринку землі пенсійна
реформа за чорт солите так і на вигляд був
осі довідкові пенсійної реформи
гидко кен і малих steam або плати
тайпан синім низьким а бізнесу через
високі праці vip подарунки
догляди будемо зберігати але дефіцитний
пенсійний фонд ти сам на бюджет
на газ усіру кінозал особистості україна
жила законами що немає ґрунтований 2 лют
як результат звивалася і газуй
олігархи заручниць види російського газу
то енергона ефективніше під спадкоємство
Вате повтори до стеження на щоб не
оптимістичну зміну що у сіце і
по малки
можна ви право ти проти комп'ютера kill